thank you so much all right well good
morning really glad to be here so today
I'm really excited to talk to you a
little bit about managing stakeholders
and this is gonna be kind of like a
hopefully a pragmatic approach to doing
data science for business in the real
world I'll try to keep it to that so Who
am I my name is Lauren Olga and I'm a
data scientist at spark beyond I have
about six years experience and
stakeholder management on projects of
various types and so I feel slightly
qualified to talk about this I'm
actually kind of a newbie to design
thinking myself so be gentle in the the
comments if that's something that you're
going to talk about but there's gonna be
other tidbits in here as well so just to
give you a brief outline we're gonna
need to talk about how to identify a
stakeholder what is a stakeholder and
then maybe some techniques for empathy
and Trust building that up talking about
how to select a use case with kind of
this design thinking mindset and also
really really important whenever you're
working with a client or something like
this as setting expectations so spark
Beyond is a client facing role it's a
client facing company where data
scientists we work on an auto ml
platform and use it to work on clients
problems data problems and those clients
are various sizes
sometimes small public companies
sometimes large fortune 500s
I think the use cases that I'm going to
talk about today are kind of the smaller
companies large companies it gets a
little bit tricky politically at times
and so we'll keep the the conversation a
little bit more focused but my hope is
that even if you're not client facing
this will still be a valuable talk for
you because I think many of the
techniques that you can use here with an
outside team external to your company
can also be used kind of internally
sometimes as a data scientist your bit
siloed
and it takes some political maneuvering
let's say to convince people that you
know you do something that's useful for
them and it's not just like analysis
that sits on a shelf and and and they
want to see the numbers but then they do
whatever they want you know so hopefully
hopefully you'll be able to take some
techniques away and kind of the other
part of the motivation for this talk is
that you know for as much as I tried to
find headlines to put here that's like a
is magic and when I was searching for it
it was all these headlines that are like
a is not magic but like even though
those are the headlines we know that
there's people out there that think AI
is magic right so it you it comes up in
conversation all the time it's all the I
don't know the Elon Musk stuff of the
world that people have been sold on I
couldn't find any particular picture to
put here but you know it's true you know
that people in their mind they they
think about that so let's talk about
identifying stakeholders let's let's get
real so where does this concept of
stakeholder come from it was kind of
interesting I I did a little bit of
research into it because we talked about
stakeholders but where is this actually
from so in the 1950s there was this a
approach to thinking about a company as
a closed system right and then it wasn't
until the 80s that systems thinkers
started to say no actually companies are
our open systems and they're subject to
their environment and you know the
choices of their customers and things
like this and so this is not a
particularly customer centric diagram as
you can see when this was first
published in 81 but it is a recognition
that there is multiple forces that a
company really needs to think about
right and I want you to take that
mindset when you're thinking about your
data science project right isn't there's
there's going to be multiple for your
you're an open system right there's
going to be multiple things that you
need to kind of scan for and be aware of
so a stakeholder is anyone who's
affected by or has an interest in your
project and the traditional approach
would be to just kind of like fill in
this chart right and
at first its kind of skeptical right
like okay that's kind of well we'll see
if this is useful
you got the contact person the power and
the interest and if you fill it in it
might might look something like this so
just to split it up on on slides this is
the business side right so maybe you've
got the c-suite and perhaps they
received the steerer codec maybe they
maybe they look at it maybe they don't
they're probably only getting involved
if they have like a specific ask or if
they become interested later oh we're
we're paying this third-party vendor
anyway let's see what they can do for us
all right that's kind of the c-suite
mentality project managers oftentimes
the project manager is managing just one
or two or three projects right so they
may be promoted if your project goes
well so they're incredibly engaged and
they're also kind of your best point of
interest point of conduct excuse me to
ask who who knows what what you know who
what what introductions can they make
for you on the on the client side mm-hmm
okay the business vertical owners would
be like your KPI owners and you're going
to want to engage them heavily but
there's a lot of demands on their time
they're kind of like middle management
right so you're not the only thing that
they're working on and then of course
there's the field right if you want your
thing to eventually be actionable it's
very important to consider that there is
this field component that you are going
to make recommendations for experiments
that you want them to run perhaps right
things that they want that you want them
to change but there might be additional
incentives that you know for example
they they don't want to change it
because all right so I'll give you like
a real example right that's what you're
here for
so let's say that you want to change how
how different insurance agents are hired
right hired and fired and and things
like this but the the results of your
analysis main may or may not be used
because you didn't understand that
the people on the ground make the
ultimate decision for hiring and firing
right and that their pay is linked to it
right so they're not easily going to
change what they know works based on you
know some Outsiders one-off analysis
right so it's just kind of understanding
the the the interests and incentives of
the field is really important okay
it's getting a little verbose but stick
with me there's also the technology side
so we have the business side here's the
technology side and so here in the this
theoretical example that we've filled in
here your sponsor is actually the CIO
right and they provide the budget and
maybe a little bit of the strategic
vision but realistically they're not
super engaged with the business side
they kind of want to show that they're
doing something cool by bringing in
third parties but but you know it's it's
a technology directive and we'll see why
that's a problem in a second um then we
also have our data engineer maybe
they're on a temporary contract right
they've been hired just to help you with
the data poles to support the project so
they're extremely motivated you got IT
which is extremely demotivated because
they've got plenty on their plate
already and you know who is this one-off
person that we're going to be working
with for a couple of months you got the
data scientists who are super excited to
be working with you finally they get you
know a friend someone that that knows
and speaks their language but maybe
their boss isn't involved in this
project at all and you have no idea what
the demands on their time are right so
you can kind of fill this out and you
can start to see the usefulness of it I
don't know that it's like the most
useful thing but oh sorry
and before I forget most importantly
although this kind of drops by the
wayside is in stakeholder analysis you
have to consider who's actually going to
be affected in the end right so who are
the end users and in this case like the
debit card users are the direct deposit
users they can leave they can go to
another competitor's product and they
have competing interests and whether or
not you engaged them is kind of well it
would be good to engage them but
realistically I haven't seen that too
often okay so in the traditional
approach again so how would we actually
use this you would maybe make a graph
that's like interest versus power and
then you kind of like plot where people
land and then that gives you a strategy
and I don't know I this I don't like
this part of the traditional approach
right I I think this is not very useful
because what does it mean to keep the
what does it mean to monitor the IT
right what like how what how are you
going to keep informed the data
engineering right so it so it doesn't
quite map on very interestingly but what
you do get from doing this process is
identifying really really key players
right so you're really key player here
is definitely going to be your KPI owner
right going through this process and
listing out who has the biggest interest
in your key performance indicator right
who has key performance indicators that
they collect data on and who is measured
against those and who has the incentive
to improve those and who knows where
that data sits right your your KPI owner
is actually your most critical person
and also doing this can maybe make you
understand that you actually had the
wrong point of entry right so our
sponsor in this case is not the KPI
honor its it's someone that's been hired
recently they want to kind of show off
their help hoping that you help them do
that
right and there's the promise of scaling
to other regions if it goes well but
they have other projects right and it's
kind of like they're going to they're
going to remove all the bottlenecks for
you but they're not necessarily going to
be able to provide you with what you
need to get started right like just
being on the ground doesn't doesn't get
you a predictive
and something where you could you know
put a model into production so let's
think for a second
with a kind of a more Design Thinking
approach right so the traditional
approach is okay you get you get some
things out of it I think it's a little
uh you know handwriting me for what you
get out of it but it's okay it's good to
like think it through and do it with
your team but in design thinking you
really want to think about pains gains
and jobs to be done so for example we
could really dive deep into this KPI
owner all right so what are their pains
in this debit card company prepaid debit
card company fraudulent disputes are
highly regulated that's a major pain for
them right they're constrained in their
actions you can they contract out their
customer service right maybe overseas
and so they don't have direct control
over that although they can kind of make
recommendations or a playbook but you
know as far as being on the ground they
are not co-located with customer service
that's a pain not all charge backs to
merchants that that are possible have
been charged back right if you book a
hotel room and and then you decide not
to right like sometimes that money
doesn't get charged back and so not all
the charge backs that were possible and
are allowed by regulation have been
charged back these these are their pains
right and you can start to see how by
listing these out the pains the gains
the jobs to be done you can get a better
sense of like okay this is starting to
sound a little bit more like a
predictive problem that I would want to
work on right how can we find fraudulent
disputes that or how can we find
disputes that are most likely to be
fraudulent right and ones that are not
unavailable to us through regulation
right that sounds like a good predictive
problem yeah we can go over the gains
motivated team is experienced in machine
learning or sorry is not experienced in
machine learning but
understands the data understands this
business that's really critical right
you might have to kind of go in circles
to figure out what a machine learning
problem is in order for excuse me for a
person like this you might you might
need to iterate with them a little bit
to kind of figure out where to land as
far as like alright how do we structure
this question but at least they know
their business and then jobs to be done
okay so let's not beat that to death but
I did want to bring it up to you so I
talked a little bit about entry point an
entry point is kind of it's pretty
important when you're working with
clients in that you need a champion for
your project right and I really like
this framework from t4g because really
it says that okay we've got unhappy
people kind of on the Left which is the
the technology side and and happy people
on the business side and the idea is
that if you want your project to focus
more on making him making an impact on
the business then you don't want to take
a tools based mindset right you really
want to be brought in by someone's that
has a problem and needs you to help you
help them solve it rather than to be
brought in by someone that says hey
let's apply you know the latest stuff to
whatever I'm working on you say well
what are you working on they say just do
it just stuff right so so here the
technology directive is is extremely
unhappy here you have got the KPI owners
is you know the best place to land in
our case our entry point was kind of in
this example the technology directive
but because they were CIO I didn't want
to put it totally in the the unhappy
face because I think it's like they
could get rid of the bottlenecks they
could break down the barriers but you
know it still kind of was a tool based
mission at first and to be honest so
this is from a real-life example it took
us probably two three months of like
circling around
to really find a data set that we could
work on and answer a business problem
that did matter so if you've got that
kind of runway to like iterate and you
know spend two three months figuring out
your use case then then it's fine but if
you don't have that kind of time then
maybe you need to consider what your
entry point is a little bit more
seriously okay buildings trust and
empathy so the goal of stakeholder
engagement is to turn effective parties
into participants in the project the
process to turn effective parties into
the participants of the process and so a
great way to do this is actually
in-person face-to-face and when you're
planning your your first visit the idea
is that you want to build that kind of
professional trust you want to check in
with your stakeholders make sure that
you kind of understand who they are that
your assumptions about them make sense
and you want to make sure that you're
able to introduce your two teams but the
timing of it is really important because
you must have at least received one data
delivery you do not have a project if
you have not seen their data the project
cannot start I emphasize this the
project cannot start without any data
you need to have at least kind of seen a
sample of it you have to have some idea
of what they're collecting you you
probably haven't done a full quality
analysis at this point you probably
haven't architected out there their
schema but you need to know something is
there before you can start with them and
ideally you've done to some EDA you know
find some outliers look at distributions
and and you should probably also try to
map out business processes to your the
best of your ability at this point so
that you can bring those with you and
actually iterate on them highlight the
unknowns and get those questions
answered on because these are the kinds
of things that are really better to do
face to face and you might not have so
many opportunities you know even when
you go to visit you might only have an
hour so you want to use it strategically
and so here's some actions that you can
take on-site most likely you won't even
see the CEO and that's fine but you do
want to make sure that you're spending
close time with your project manager on
there
side and hopefully they exist right not
you don't you don't necessarily have a
project manager on the other side but
it's good to kind of identify that that
is a role that you want that that's a
persona that you should request and you
know it is a useful thing to have for
sure
but it's not always guaranteed and then
you can verify your understanding of all
the stakeholders with them and then to
find new ones with your KPI owners you
really want to focus on the excuse me
you want to you want to really focus on
why you're going to do things right so
I've put here it's kind of confusing the
way I put it here you want to align the
project how with the whys so how is the
tools you're going to use but why is
what matters right why why is always
what matters and it's it sounds simple
when we say it like this but it's easy
to get lost in the contracts and in the
salesmanship that the why is really what
matters and so you really want to align
on strategic kpi's you should also
verify that you know what actual level
levers you can take right can you
actually change the hiring process can
you actually you know in the case of
regulated things can you actually
identify fraudulent transactions and and
not refund those rights something like
that so yeah and then for the field you
may or may not have access to the field
on your on-site right field is probably
not co-located with headquarters but to
the extent possible you should try to
find someone that is an owner of the
field process right so interview them to
understand and map the business
processes verify your actionable levers
and on the technology side it's really
good to just kind of touch base and know
these people because they're the ones
that you're going to be working with
right and so any outstanding issues that
you have with IT you can take care of
with your data scientists it's really
good to map out what actually are the
data sources that are available to
you and and really to talk about when is
data collected right so what are your
best sources of truth for the problem
that you're thinking about working on
what are the sampling bias is when does
data get updated and so let's talk a
little bit about selecting use case so
if you don't know where you're going any
road will take you there and that's how
it can feel with the use case at times
but that's why it's really important to
scope it out so again let's focus on the
kpi's right a KPI is great because
someone already decided it was important
and likely they've been measuring it and
they have data on that historically
right so these problems are usually well
studied and it's something that machine
learning can enhance and that's really
the sweet spot for you it might be
harder to sell it in the beginning
because again you know people want the
magic but this is definitely not the
magic this is just like an iterative
improvement on existing business
processes that'll hopefully make
everyone more money and make them
happier in the end so a couple of
different strategies for finding a use
case so you can look at sorry so one of
the strategies I've mentioned it earlier
is to bring materials in advance so when
you're bringing materials in advance to
the on site what does that look like you
should write down which data sources you
think you're going to use for each
analysis path you should highlight
anything that's unusual in your EDA
process if you've been able to complete
that at this point look at outliers look
at unexpected distributions these are
the hints these are the keys that can
help you with what should be a very
open-ended interview process right you
don't want to come in necessarily having
your list of five questions and then
those are the five questions you want
answered you could do that over email
right the benefit of face to face is
that you can actually kind of iterate
over questions and you say like alright
well what does that mean um or tell me
more right or did I understand this
correctly these are the kinds of things
that you can use another great thing to
use is and this one's real this is from
the debit card process and hopefully
it's tiny enough that it protects
identities i cropped it at the top it's
fine so you can draw out the business
process right and this obviously doesn't
happen all in one go for this by the way
we used lucid charts which is like a
tool but I'm sure there's plenty of free
ones available out there to wear so each
each diamond is a decision point if
you're not familiar with flow diagrams
but it's really helpful like as you are
iterating and talking with people and
having conversations that you're also
taking that knowledge and formalizing it
somehow so that you can bring it back to
them and say did I understand properly
right did I get it right and oftentimes
you'll say like oh no I I thought that
this was just one decision but actually
now there's four parallel processes
right it brings up those kinds of
questions and it's useful to have those
kind of conversations because really so
you know delink it back we're talking
about use cases right and you might be
working on one thing now and if you have
a you know a good strong first problem
in mind then that's great
you may or may not have that but you're
going to want to try to find out what
are their major pain points right are
you working on the problem that is the
most important right because you can
always reprioritize allocate additional
resources right and you want to
ultimately be working on something that
matters the most to the company so it's
really very valuable to map this out and
they say okay well we were working over
here but now that we think about it like
that over there is a major pain point
for us and let's talk about how we can
solve that problem too oh okay so I had
this here ah targeted and open any
questions draw it iterations yeah
requests feedback
perfect
okay this is one of my favorite ones
another strategy that you can take in
doing finding your use cases or doing an
analysis like this is conduct a
pre-mortem right it's not a post-mortem
it's a pre-mortem so before the
patient's dead what could possibly go
wrong right and this is a bit open-ended
and but it is it's kind of a nice
mindset to take two things it's like
okay wait let's imagine that we're a
couple of months from now what happened
so setting expectations setting
expectations is really important in life
in client work in communication probably
very much internally to your company
setting expectations is absolutely
critical so let's let's spend a couple
of minutes on this and I think we'll
wrap up establishing a communication
cadence in advance is really important
this comes from a you know the kind of
slide that you could share at the very
beginning at kickoff with your clients
with your own team and you know it is
the kind of thing that gets everyone on
the same page it can be hard to you know
imagine into the future how you're going
to work with these strangers so this is
not necessarily the only way to do it
but you need a way to start and any
other changes to you know your
communication cadence it'd probably be
good to revise this and then put it in
writing and send it out again right just
to make sure that everyone's on the same
page because you have to remember this
might be your number one priority but it
is definitely not everyone else's number
one priority definitely not all your
stakeholders and especially not your
executives right so making sure that
they have the most up-to-date
information they can refer to it is
really very useful I think it increases
transparency in the process which also
you know allows you to build trust so
and then this is this is a kind of a
tricky one alright everyone wants to be
agile should you scrum what do you guys
think no I heard a note all right so I'm
not a big fan of scrumming right so
scrum has when you time box things right
you say okay we're gonna have two week
Sprint's for this two week sprint this
is our goal and we're gonna work on this
and then we're going to present our
results and then we're going to have a
little bit of time at the end to reflect
on it and everyone's going to talk about
it and we're going to set our next goal
for the next scrum and realistically in
data science I don't think it works I
really don't think it works at all
because you don't know like it's really
hard to time box a data science problem
it's really hard to chunk up a data
science problem into you know parts that
makes sense right like very so so much a
data science is like iterative and you
go back and you go back and forth and
you try to figure out what you were
doing or where you started and it can be
hard to show intermediate results right
what is what is an MVP of a model well
it's just a model right and then you you
increase it you make it better but but
until you have that right like if you're
trying to join in different data sources
and say it my totally like reframe how
you've written out in the first place so
personally I'm not a big fan of
scrumming I haven't seen it work I'd be
happy to be proven wrong but that said I
don't think the agile you know you
shouldn't throw out agile right because
there's actually um I don't know if
you're familiar so there's another
process called Kanban and you say I wish
I'd pulled up a Trello board here I'll
put it in and post where you you can
create a backlog of projects and then
you just say what you're working on
right and you allow yourself to only
stage a certain number to commit to a
certain number of projects at any given
time right and those can be
reprioritized but
only the things that you have committed
to will be worked on and then you've got
a work-in-progress area and then you
complete it right and so it kind of
moves through the Trello board and I I
think it's very good a couple of things
that a couple of tips I would not let
your client reprioritize your board
directly perhaps for obvious reasons but
I do think that it's useful for someone
on your side if that's possible to have
daily touch points with someone on the
client side hopefully not you because
you know you're focused and doing
scientific work and and coding is hard
to split up into you know between
meetings let's say but yeah so if you
have a project manager on your side I
would say touch base with them
periodically based on their daily
conversations with the client and
reprioritize accordingly and that should
allow you the the best balance between
focus and control okay and then just
quickly because this is really really
important you got to be able to push
back you got to be able to say no but
the thing is you can never say no you
can never say no because you don't want
to say no right you want to say yes but
you want to understand where the request
is coming from and then you want to say
what you need right so this is this is
the political maneuvering this is this
is the jujitsu right you don't say no
you say yes but you say well you know
what do you need right so there's
there's two kinds of knows that you
should say there there's there's the
notice scope creep and there's the note
of nonsense requests and if it's a
nonsense request you just got to keep
asking questions like why why do you
want to do that and then what would we
do with it and how would that be useful
and who's going to use it right just
keep kind of pushing back on it but
you're never really saying the word and
oh right you can kind of just kind of
have that conversation and it's like
going to be a lot more fruitful and
people will think you're a lot easier to
work with
on the left-hand-side scope group is
real and you need to push back against
it there's only one of you even if
there's more of you than that there's
only n number of you right and so people
will come up with a million ideas and
you need to figure out what they
actually want right so someone says hey
can you also do X analysis you say yeah
absolutely
does that D prioritize what I'm
currently working on right is that more
important than what I'm currently
working on right forth the conversation
into prioritization and you never have
to say no to scope creep and on the
other side you could request additional
resources right you say you know
absolutely we can do that I've got a
colleague that could come onto this
project and you know then we'll have two
of us working on it that's less ideal
because the more number of people it the
larger number of people that you have
working on a project the more points a
communication failure there are right
and a skill is kind of like
geometrically so you don't really want
to add more people to your project if
you can help it
but it's a good it's another way to push
back if they say no no no both of these
are high priority right these are both
high priority projects everything's high
priority so that's it my name is Lauren
Olga I'm a data scientist and find me
around the conference thanks so much